とは この仏教において大変大事な言葉なんです
それはこの他の宗教にしたっても
あの死ということ中心的な思考なんですよ
で なんで人間が宗教というものを考え出したかというと
このもう人が死んじゃうんだからなんですね
で それはどんどん死んでいっちゃうし
それでなんで死ぬ死ぬことが宗教になってしまったんでしょうかね
それはこの仏教以前 この他の仏教以前からもね
宗教というものはございましたから
そういう人々がなんでそういうこと
死は宗教の  なんて言いますかね
ファウンデーション あるいは土台
宗教はこの死という概念から発生しているものなんですね
なんで死ぬということは宗教にしたんでしょうかと
で 昔の人々だったらね
もうだいたい獲物を取って食べてしていましたし
原始的な人々がまあ生きたままでね
まあ鹿やら牛やら食べられませんね
ですから死んだ死なないと
だから死ぬことというのは
死体ということは まあまあ自分の餌やと思った方がもっと具体的な考え方になるんでしたけどね
なるはずでしたけど で
魚取ったっても 一旦まあ生きているままでは食べませんし
食べられませんし それはまあなんとかまあ死んでから死体を焼いたりして食べていましたからね
だからこの動物なんかは死ぬということはよくよく見ていたんだけど
同じくもう人間も死んだところで
なんか違うことを考えちゃったんですね
それはどういうことかというと
やっぱりこの牛やら鹿やらね
死んでもらった方が美味しいものを食べられるんだけど
なんか自分の周りの人々が死んでいくと
それは嫌だと思ったんですよ
それは嫌だと だから自分にとっては嫌なことを起きてるんですね
好ましくないことが起きてるんですよ
それに何とかまあしなくちゃいけないと考えていたところで
いろいろ宗教的な概念が生まれてきたんですよ
だから人間っていうのは
まあ動物はまあ置いといて
人間は人間死ぬのは嫌ですかと
人間が他の人間が死ぬことを嫌だと思ってますかと
そうじゃないんです 他の人だったら死んだ方がいいと思ってるんです
自分の周りの人々は死んでほしくない
他の人だったら死んでしまえと
関係ないんだと と思ってるんですよ
普通は ですから この原始時代でも
それからどんどんね まあ人間にも結構歴史がありますから
で 昔はまあ平気で隣の村に村ではなくてね
原始時代のこというと
もうちょっと山を森を通ってどこか行ったら
他の人間に出会ったら
その人々戦って その人々を殺したりする
それでアフリカでしたっけかな
首狩り民族ももう最近まで生きていたんだからね
ですから もう人間見たら捕まって殺して食べる人々もいましたけど
それは少ないし おそらくおいしくなかったでしょうね
で 食べる人は少なかったんだけど
一応首でも取って それはいろいろ加工して小さくして
腰に巻いて持っていくわ
首にかけて どうだい 俺がヒーローではないかっていう感じで
で 威張っている だからそれはもう関係ない人だったら死んでしまえということなんですね
それはもう原始時代のことでね
我々はそんなね 悪いこと
みっともないことしませんねと思ってるんだけど
これは大違いで 今考えているのはどうすればまあ 1億人
2億人でもいっぺんに殺せるかということを今考えているんですよ
今の人間の考え方は まあどうすればもう自分が完全安全状態にいて
他人は完璧に全面的に破壊できるかと
まあ例えば地球の中でもなんか穴でも掘って
洞窟でも掘って隠れていても
爆発しなくても殺される方法はないかと
超音波やらいろんな電波やらいろんな放射能やら
もう何とかでも使って
たとえ隠れていても殺される方法ないかとかね
それから最近と言ったっても
この４０年の間で作った武器の中
例えば人々が森の中に隠れていると
もう見えないんですね
飛行機から で 見える眼鏡があるんですよ
で 人間っていうのは体があったかいんだから
木よりは温度が高いんですよ
だから動物の体の温度はまた少々違います
例えば猫だったら人間よりは体温が高いし
で まあ象なんかは少々少ないだろうと思いますけどね
ですから 人間の体温は知ってるんですよ
そこでその温度でどれぐらい温度があるかと
これで映像で映っちゃうんですね
そこで簡単に動物と人間の区別できます
動物はこの４つの足で歩くんだから
温度の映像が横になってるんですね
人間っていうのはバカだから立って歩くんでしょうに
森の中でも そうすると縦線の映像が映っちゃうんですね
あっ これ人間やと もし熊でもね
何か木に何かでもハチハチミツでも食べようかなと立ってところで
まあ間違って熊も人間やと間違う可能性あります
あまり間違わないんですよ
もう熊の体の構造違いますから
足が短いんだから 人間より
ですから 森の中に隠れていても
もう夜夜でも見える 今の戦争っていうのは
飛行船の先端技術で爆弾を落とす場合はすべて夜なんです
だから 普通の街に生活している人と村に生活する人々にはどうにもできない状態で
技術とか何も持ってないんだから
夜は暗いんだから寝るしか方法ないんですね
その時 真っ暗闇で飛行機が明確に全部見て
で 爆弾を落とすというふうに技術開発していて
大変素晴らしい世界です
だから この人間っていうのは昔からあまり考え方は変わってないんですよ
自分の身内が死んでほしくない
他の人間はもう死んでしまえと
という考え方なんですね
それでも宗教はどこから始めたかというと
この私の身内の人々は死んでほしくないという
考え方からまあ発生しているんですよ
皆様あまり賛成したくないと思いますけど
もう私もあまり言いたくないんだけど
やっぱり事実はそういう事実なんですね
このマスコミみたいにあったものは
もう何といいますか もう変えてみんなの気持ちよくするようなストーリーは私は言いたくないんですね
ただ 事実そのまま言いたく
事実はあまり面白くないんです
ですから 自分の親が死んでほしくない
自分の子供が死んでほしくない
自分と一緒に仲良くしている知り合いの人々が
一緒にいる人々が死んでほしくない
だから神様にお祈りしましょうという概念なんですよ
だからそれは美化して
とことんとことん美化して
死に対するすごいことを私は喋るべきかないかと
とも疑問 私にも一応あります
まあとりあえずそんなことだとまずわかってほしい
人間っていうのは この死ぬのは嫌がりますけど
本当のところはどういうことかと
他人の死はもう何のこともない
何の気持ちも何のこともなく
もう冷静に認める 死んだ方がいいと思う
他人が死ぬ場面なんか見て喜びまで感じる
やれやれと エールまで送ったりする
でも 自分の身内の場合になったと
また態度が違いますね
なんでなぜそんなことを言ったかというと
このあまりこの宗教の世界で死に関して言ってることっていうのは
あの程度のことだから
もうあんまりそれもそんなに真剣に考えなくてもいいということなんですよ
なぜかと聖書にも一行あるんですよ
イエス イエスが言うんですね
私はユダヤ人を救うために来たんだと
自分の民族のだけのことなんですね
他人はどうなってもいいというふうに思っているんですよ
日本で仏教だと大変思って尊敬している
このインドのヒンドゥー教
これ 人類のために語っているんじゃないんですよ
あれはバラモン人たちだけの教えなんですよ
こちらでいくら護摩焚いたりいろいろやったりしたって
もうカースト違いますから
おそらく天国に行かないかもしれません
それはバラモン人が天国に行くために作った教えなんです
ですから 宗教の話を聞いて
ちょっと少々聞いてみてください
聞いてみると 自分の仲間が天国に行く話なんですよ
人類が天国に行く話は言ってないんです
まあとにかくお釈迦様が言うのは
この我々に この伝統的にみんなこの言ってる考え方っていうのは
そのままはい正しい はい正しいと言うんじゃなくて
新しい視点というか 新しい角度で
もっと客観的な角度で物事を見た方がいいんです
何でも素晴らしい 何でも素晴らしい
古いものだったら何でも素晴らしいと
もう言いたがる気持ちはまあわからないわけでもないんだけど
これはもうずっとみんなやってるんだからやってることで
古いものだったら素晴らしいものだとかね
古い人々の思考だったら素晴らしい思考だとかね
まあそういう勝手に言うんだけど
ちょっと見たらね それほどことでもない可能性もあるし
それなりに素晴らしい思考もある場合もあるし
まあとにかく死に対しては
まあ人間はこういう考え方を持ってるんですね
私の身内の人々は死ぬのは嫌ですと
そのところは理解できます
身内の人々が死んじゃったら
自分が損するんですよ
自分すごくもう楽しく楽しく遊んでいる
自分の子供があっちこっちもう走り回って
もうものすごく まあもうなんていうのはにぎやかでうるさくて遊んでいる
子供が突然熱でも出して倒れて死んじゃったら
なんかすごく悲しくなる
自分が損しちゃうんですね
自分の奥さんでも死んでしまっちゃったら
もう子供を残しちゃって
これ大変なことなんですよ
だから嫌だと思っちゃうんですね
奥さんにしたっても もう食べ物を持ってくる男が突然死んでしまったら
自分がどのように子供を食べさせるかと
で 問題が出てくるんだから
だからもう身内の人々が死ぬのは嫌ということになるんです
それ私がね いつでも失礼なことを言うんだからね
嘘を言っていると思ってるでしょ
この坊主は何か変なことばっかり知ってるんだから
これも大した根拠はないんだと思ってるんですけど
我々もたとえ親戚であろうとも
ものすごい嫌な人がいて
例えば財産に対して裁判かけるわ
喧嘩するわ いろんなひどいことをするわと
そうやって自分のものすごい嫌なわがままで嫌な親戚がいて
死んじゃったりする その時悲しみますかね
あ やっと死んだかと思いますね
その時は だから身内の人でも
自分にとってすごく嫌な人だったら
まあそういうのも時々ありますからね
例えば兄弟同士でも兄弟だから仲良くするということも
まあいつでもあるわけじゃないんですね
まあ兄弟っていうのはほとんどは仲良くしていますけど
たまたまもうものすごい嫌な人も兄弟として生まれてくるんだから
どうしようもないんですよ
そこでも一番普通のは
例えば兄弟二人 三人がいる
で まあわがままっていうのは
長男とかね かなりわがままだからね
それで親の面倒を何も見ないで
もう平気でも家を出て
自分勝手に生活する でも親にしたらやっぱり長男だから
まあかなり可愛いんですよ
それでも親をいくら裏切っても
親にいくら邪魔をしたっても
どこかでその人の面倒を見てあげたりするということは
まあ親は親としてもうやってしまうんですね
それで親が病気になって倒れて
一年 十年とかね 十五年ぐらいっても
病気でずっと看病しなくちゃいけなくなったところで
次男かもう次の長女か誰か 3番目の人とか
まあまあ性別やめましょう
一応 1番目の子供がそうなったら
2番目か 3番目の子がまあ一生懸命親の面倒を見たりする
それでお見舞いにでも来てくださいと頼んだっても
もう来てこない 来ない
で 兄弟もあまり仲が良くないんだから
兄弟同士でも喧嘩したりもする
そこで 3番目の人があるいは 2番目の人が一生懸命親のことを見て
まあ上の人がどうでもいいということで面倒を見る
そういう人が親が死んだ時だけすぐ来るんです
死んでから 来ていきなり葬式どうですか？ではなくて
この家は俺のものだと
俺が長男だから 今まで親の面倒見た人々を追い出しちゃって
全部財産を自分のものにしようとするということは
まあないわけじゃないんですよ
そういう話 私はまああまり日本の皆様のことを知りませんだけど
私さえもちゃんと本人から具体的に聞いたことがありますから
死んでから財産自分のものだと
そこまでは知りません
親は だからそういうふうなもう家族も時々出てきますし
それで 身内の人はみんな死ぬのは楽しいか
嫌ということでもないんですよ
本当にものすごい嫌な
すごい迷惑する人だったら
たとえ兄弟であろうとも
たとえ親であろうとも
死んだ方がいいと思う時もあります
その時も全然 もうやっぱり法事やりなくちゃいけないとか
お墓参りしなくちゃ そういう気持ちもないんですよ
死んでから できれば忘れちゃいますね
周りが何か文句を言うんだったら
まあ一応それも自分の社会的な立場を守るためにやってあげるぐらいのことで
ですから 人間 本当に死ということを考えているんですかと
それぐらいの見方でみんな死について語る
ターミナルケアについても語る
ホスピスについても語る
ホスピス制度とかね 老人問題
どうしましょうかと語る
でも見てください 誰一人も真面目じゃないでしょ
できればやりたくないってことでしょ
できればやりたくない
例えば日本はこの老人
老人 老人問題というかね
これからたくさん老人が出てくるんだと
これは大変な迷惑という角度で国会で議論しているんです
大変な迷惑だと それは口では言わない
もし私が間違ったら直してください
私はあまり日本語を理解できるというところではないんだけど
一応国会の議論とかは聞いてはいます
勉強になりますから 勉強になりますよ
ですから聞いてはいるんだけど
あれ 本当かと 本当にやりたくて
どうやればいいかということを考えているか
これは考えているのはもうお金がなくなっちゃうんだと
損するんだと 損する でもまあ迷惑ですね
この年取った連中は一遍に死んでくれればいいんだけど
死んでもくれませんし
そんなこと言ったら自分がもう次の選挙で負けちゃうし
まあしょうがない まあなんとかしようというぐらいのことで考えたりはします
だからはっきりした答えが出てこない
はっきりした この年取ってから
老後 死ぬまで安心して幸せで楽しく
最後の人生をね 生きる
この覚悟というかね そういうものは全然出てこない
例えば日本の方々には
日本で生まれてよかったと
もう年取って何もできなくなっても
結構楽しく生きていられるんだと
社会がね もうちゃんと守ってくれるんだと
そういうシステムっていうのは一向に出てこないでしょ
老後は心配ないと ですから
私が言いたがっているのは
人間っていうのは 死に対してのアプローチはすごい
それほど美しいものではないということなんですね
それほど心を広く見ているわけじゃないんです
他人だったら まあ関係ないし
死んだ方がいいと 他人は負けた方がいいと
自分は負けたくはないんだと
自分の身内は死んでほしくないと
で それでも嫌な人はまあ死んだ方がいいと
身内の中でも その立場で身内の人が死ぬ
あ これ大変だ どうしましょうか
神様は助けてくれませんかと聞くでしょ
助けてくれますかね 神様がいたってもね
そんな調子だったら まあまあ
そこをまず理解して ですから
仏教も結局死ということは
すごくものすごい大事なポイントとして扱っているんです
これは考え直さなくてはならないんだと
もっと目を覚ませなくてはならないんだと
なぜかというと 私たちがこの今日のテーマ
話のポイントは 嫌という言葉
たった一言葉なんです
いや 嫌です 嫌いです たったそれだけですから
話いくら伸びたっても
その一言葉だけ覚えておいてください
そうすると全部今日の話の内容はわかります
その嫌という一言葉を中心にして
この話は回しているだけ
そこで死に対して私はなぜ私たちがなぜ
いろんなことを考えるかというと
身内の人々は死ぬのは嫌
プラス私も死ぬのは嫌と
この私も死ぬのが嫌ですということが推測なんです
身内の人々は死に死ぬことは見えているんだから
それは実感なんですね
自分の死は単なる推測で
で 嫌と考える そこで嫌と考えるのはいいんだけど
そこで人間もう一つやっちゃうんですよ
死ぬんだっていうことは嫌なことだから認めないんですね
認めない それで頭の中で明確にある一つの命令というか
コマンドというか ある一つの
言葉が刷り込まれているんですよ
それは私が死にませんという言葉なんです
私が死にません だから自分の心
自分の気持ち ちょっといじってみてください
そこに基本的にあるのは私が死にませんという決まりなんです
まあ昭和 を出そうとすればいくらでも出せますよ
我々にとっては 私が死にません
生きているんだということから
このエネルギーでやるというか
この生きるもう勇気というか
頑張る気持ちというか
すべて私が死にませんだからやっているんですよ
生きているんだから 生きているんだから
バカでかい建物 家作らなくちゃいけない
生きているんだから バカ高い車買わなくちゃいけない
生きているんだから もっと美しくならなくちゃいけないんだと
生きているんだから もっと体重を減らしてスマートにならなくちゃいけないんだと
自分が生きているんだから
敵を倒さなくちゃいけないんだと
だから人々はいろんなこの金を儲かる
いろんなものを集めるでしょう
人間っていうのは いろんなものを集める
集める 集める 集める ちょっと量は知らない
まあ動物もいますよ この集める動物は
このもうミツバチやらアリやら
あのな 葉っぱなんか取ってきて集めるアリがいるでしょ
そういう葉っぱを持っていて
自分のアリ塚の中に置いておいて
その上でこのカビが出てくるんですね
そのカビを食べて生活しているんですよ
ちゃんとまあ畑作っているんです
カビといっても 人間でいえばしいたけみたいなもんなんですね
だから自分たちがしいたけではないんだけど
小さなこのマッシュルームの種類みたいなカビなんですけど
で しいたけのカビの一種だからね
それは自分で作って まあ食べている
まあでもアリたちももうあまりよく考えない場合はね
もう葉っぱなんか取りすぎとかあったら中で栽培できなくなっちゃうし
とにかくそれぐらいのことを動物もやってはいることはやってますけど
でもそういうのは社会問題になったことはないんですね
あのアリたちに葉っぱ取られて
もうもう森が大変な危機になったとかね
はないんです あるいはアリ塚の中で葉っぱはたまりすぎて
土がおかしくなったとかね
地面が柔らかくなったとかいうふうな社会問題にはなってないんです
でも 人間がものを集める
集める 集める それはもう社会問題
地球問題にまで発展しているんですね
きりがなく集める なぜ集めるかというと
自分たちが永遠に生きているんだからなんです
だから この 時々人々が昔
お城とか作ったりしたでしょ
イギリスなんかのお城やらね
ヨーロッパのお城なんかは
まあもう今３０0年とか400年のお城とかありますよ
400年前で作ったお城なんですけど
いまだに生活できる ものすごい豪華で
で いろんな人が作った宮殿とかあるでしょうに
フランスでもね 有名なもう驚くほどの有名ななんとかね
ヴェルサイユですか そういう宮殿とかあるでしょうに
あれはこれからも何年
何百年でも持てるでしょ
でも作った人があれで何十年住んでいたんですかね
だから自分の命は短くて
もうすぐ殺されますよと知っていたならば
あるいは自分がせいぜい５年だよと思ったならば
あんなものは作らないはずなんですよ
だから 私は永遠なりと死にませんという気持ち
確実に心の中にある 私は死にませんと
そいつは死んだってもね
私は死にません その考え方で生きているんですよ
だからそこをごまかしてはいけません
いつでもごまかしちゃう
まあたまたま口先だけで
まあせいぜい今私はあと20年でしょうとかね
自分の家はほとんど短命だからね
私もまあそんな長生きできるわけない
あんな嘘ですよ あれは
あれは真面目に言っているわけじゃないんです
それは嘘 私は死にませんという
この土台があって 心の中に作られた主観があって
その上で人生設計しているんです
だから人生設計っていうのは
すべてできるだけ長持ちできるようにと作っちゃうんですね
すべて自分のものにしたくなる
だから 他の人の生き方っていうのは迷惑になるんですよ
他の人々も同じことをやると
かなり迷惑なんですね
で トラブルになったりもします
だから我々はというのは
人類みんな 私が死にませんという立場で生きています
なぜ死にませんという立場が作ったかというと
死ぬのは嫌ということがありますね
私が死ぬのは嫌ですと
私は死ぬのは嫌でしたということは実感かというと
そうでもありません それは身内の人々が死んだところで
悲しみ 苦しみを味わったんですね
で そこからなんとか推測して
ちょっとした推測なんですね
だったら私も死ぬかもしれませんということは
その推測の上で私は死にませんとまるっきり違う
嫌でない考え方を作る
死ぬのは嫌だったら死にませんという言葉ほどありがたい
気持ちいい 賛成できる言葉がこの世の中でないんですよ
だから永遠な命を与えますよと言えば
どんな人も騙すことはできるんです
何でもします 永遠な命
そういうことだから このいろいろな宗教の宣伝文句
少々考えてみてください
みんな何を約束するかというと
永遠な命というものを約束するんですね
なぜかというと あれほど
気持ちいい言葉がないんですよ
あれほど耳が喜ぶ言葉がないんですね
ですから 宗教は死ということを真面目に考えていないんです
宗教が答えているのは
私が死にませんという馬鹿げたことを考えている人々の機嫌を取っているだけなんです
私は死にませんということは
どう見ても事実ではありませんでしょうに
経験したことがないかもしれませんだけど
まあ物事を考えてみると
それは事実ではありません
そんな長くしゃべらなくても
前の紹介でね 死というのは実感は我々にないとね
鈴木さんが言いましたからね
そういうことなんですよ
こんな実感はないんです
実感はないんだけど ちょっと考えれば死なないわけもないということぐらいはありますよ
それは気持ちではなくて
頭で考えると まあやっぱり死ぬでしょうということは出てきます
ですから この 私は死にませんというふうな
この変なことを考える人々をおだてて
その人々の機嫌を取るために
天国妄想するは 極楽堂を妄想するは
また何かの永遠な境地を妄想するとかね
それで問題解決するかというと
解決しないんですね 結局は
なぜ解決しないかというと
この基本的なところの間違いを直してないんですね
だから仏教の特色は この嘘は嫌ということ
たとえかっこよくても嘘は嫌だと
たとえ恐ろしくても事実知りたいと
真理を知りたいと たとえ面白くなくても
たとえ怖いものであろうとも
ごまかしは嫌と 真理 ありのままの事実
本当のことを知りたいというのは初期仏教の立場なんです
あとでそれまた変わってしまいましたけどね
まあ人間も仏教も人間やらなくちゃいけないんだから
人間みんな死ぬのは嫌な連中だから
やっぱり仏教の中でまたいろんな話が出てきたんですよ
慰め言葉が じゃあそれでどのようにブッダがお釈迦様が死に対応するんですかと
まず必要なのは このわてわての頭の中に刷り込まれている
あの真っ赤な嘘をなくすことなんですよ
真っ赤な嘘に基づいて哲学を作ったら
その哲学すべて根拠がなくなっちゃうんです
いいことを言っているかもしれません
例えば世界の平和 人類の平和
みんなに優しくすることことやら
俺はいっぱい宗教の世界でも哲学の世界でも言ってますよ
決して悪いことじゃないんです
みんなで分かち合って
ものを財産ね 独り占めにしてはいけませんとか
苦しんでいる人々を助けなくてはいけないんだと
そういう話はいくらでもあります
いい話は いい話はたくさんあるんだけど
これはどんな土台で どんなファウンデーションで作った建物かというと
これは私は死にませんというファウンデーションの上で
その基礎 そのところの上でできたんだから
まああんまりどうかなと
根拠はないでしょうと
ですから 仏教の最初のこの
狙いというか まあ目的というかね
まあそれはこの私は死にませんという
この真っ赤な嘘を消すことなんですよ
ですから 私が死にますよと
それを瞑想しなさいと
ヴィパッサナーは瞑想ではありません
普通 世の中に瞑想もありますけど
ヴィパッサナーという我々紹介しているのは
あれは瞑想ではありません
それは心育てるちょっとした実践であって
ちゃんとしたプログラムなんですね
瞑想っていうのはそういうちゃんとしたプログラムではなくて
ある特別な訓練なんです
ヨーガは瞑想なんですね
いろんな瞑想法が世の中にあります
いろんなことを念じることも瞑想の一種なんですね
いろいろ宗教の文句がありますね
南無阿弥陀仏 南無妙法蓮華経
おーん それから何でしたっけね
オームマニパドメフームとかね
仏教系のお祈り文句 呪文がありまして
それはキリスト教にもありますし
他の宗教にもそうやって念じる
お経 文句というか 聖なる言葉っていうものはあるんですよ
それはすごい神秘的な力があるんだとかね
何回でも念じれば念じるほどご利益が出てくるんだとか
いろんなことを今言ったりもします
そういう何かを念じることを瞑想の一種な一種なんですね
ですから 仏教でこの瞑想として私が死にますと瞑想しなさい
私が死にますということ
そう 私が死にますとすっと念じちゃうと
私が死にませんというあの土台が崩れちゃうんですね
それでどうなるかというと
私が死にません だから何だかんでももう集めて
人のものでも何でももう自分のものにして
自分のためにどんなことでもするんだよという哲学が違う哲学になる
私が死にます で どうすればいいかと
その死ぬというとこまで
死ぬという出来事起こるまでどうすればいいかという違う哲学が生まれてくるのです
その哲学は完全な平和的で友好的で調和的で
攻撃 攻撃 競争っていうのは消えちゃうんですよ
だから私が死にますという人にも
マイホーム作れますよ
作れないわけないんだから
私は今二十歳だ それで死ぬことは死ぬんだけど
まあせいぜい 70ぐらいで死ぬでしょうというと
あと 50年ありますね
じゃあこの 50 まあ家を作るんだったら
50 年もてばいいやと
で  50年だけもてる家を作る
400 年もてる家は作れません
そこでさらに計算すると
若い時は家を作ると もうあの
まあ子供 3人がいるんだったら
子供にもう部屋とかね
いろいろ計画立てて作ったりもしますけど
結局は子供が大きくなっちゃって
みんな出て行っちゃうんですね
家に残るのは夫婦だけなんですよ
それで部屋は 4つぐらいたくさんなるものを作ったっても
もう自分が体が弱くなってくる時に
時になってくると 家に誰もいない
自分が元気で何でもできる時は
子供たちはいっぱい もううるさくて
もう部屋にも喧嘩するし
お兄ちゃんと一緒の部屋は嫌ですよと
私に別の部屋が必要ですよと
そうやって喧嘩までしたりして
親もやっぱりもうどうせ大きくなっちゃいますからね
一緒はダメやとか思ったりもして困ったりはするんだけど
それで作りますよ 大きな家が
大きな家を作るんだけど
自分の体が弱くなってくると一人もいない
もう掃除もできない という状態に
ですから 私が死にますということを思う人も生きてはいるんだけど
その人は隣の国と戦争しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
相手を殺してまででもして
他人のものを取らなくちゃいけないんだとか
そうは思わないんですよ
ここまで頑張らなくたってもいいんだと
人生は無駄にしてはいけないんだということを考えちゃうんですよ
だから いまだに世の中にない生き方っていうのは出てくるはずなんですよ
私が死にますという 思考から何か考え出すと
そこで私が死にますという瞑想が実感瞑想ではありません
そこでこの仏教は まあもうただなめるだけの先生方は
あの なんか偉そうにそんな瞑想を指導したりするようなことも聞いたこともありますけどね
で 私にもいろいろ言われたことがあります
この死という瞑想を教えてくださいませくれませんか？とかね
私はまあほとんど聞いてないふりをしたりする
それで結果として この人はあんまりわからないんだと
かなり批判されたりもする
それであんまりわからないと言ってくると
私にとってはそれはすごいありがたい話なんですよ
もう簡単に何か喋って逃げればいいんだからね
わかってるんだと思ったらえらい期待するでしょ
ですから私は本当は喋りたくないんです
言いたい 言うとこんな調子になりますからね
聞きたくない話ばっかりするんです
もっと喋りたい気持ちで喋ったら
そんな調子でもないんです
今日もいい加減であんまり喋りたくないという気持ちで喋ってます
もう喋りたいと 死にそいいた語りだと思ったら
こんな調子ではないかもしれません
真相はそれよりは 2 3倍早く行動すると思います
言ったらですから この私もそういうことはね
これは大変いい結果になったということで喜んじゃいますけどね
わかりませんと言われたら
仏教のことはね とにかく私は気をつけ
私はそういうことじゃなくて
このやたらにやっても意味がないんですよ
やたらに何か念じたんだからといって
これは何の意味もないんです
ある方に聞いたんだけど
あの まあすごくこの瞑想の
教えてくれたんだと どういうふうに瞑想をなさいます？と聞いたら
私が死にます 死ぬ 死ぬ
死ぬ 死ぬと瞑想しているんだと
あ そうですか なるほど
それで終わったんだけど
人の瞑想に入り浸る必要ないんだからね
そうやっては瞑想になりません
死の瞑想になりません
あれ 変な考え方でね 死ぬ死ぬと思ったって
心の中で死にたくないんですけど
死ぬ 死にたくないんだけど
死ぬ これ どんどん嫌になっちゃいますよ
何でもいいです 食べたくないんだけど
食べなくちゃいけない
食べたくないんだけど
すごく嫌な気持ちになるでしょうに
例えば結婚してから この人と一緒にいたくない
でもいなくちゃいけない
一緒に生きたくても これでものすごいストレス溜まって
すごい大変な結果になりますよ
だからそれぐらいでも心の働きを理解しないで
死ぬ死ぬ死ぬと瞑想したっても
死の瞑想にはなりっこありません
だからそこら辺はすごく危険性がありまして
瞑想の世界ではちゃんと分かった人が正しく指導するんであって
遊びではちょっと気をつけた方がいいと思います
それでじゃあ今日は死の瞑想はの基本的なところ
どういうものかと 瞑想のやり方ではなくてね
瞑想の根拠というかね
基礎構想は説明しますけど
この死観というのは死観ですよ
死観というのは あの 漢字はどんな漢字でしたっけ？見るでしょうね
で 一つの哲学なんです
一つのビジョンなんです
智慧なんです 感情ではありません
ですから これ感情になると精神的におかしくなるんです
そこら辺気をつけてほしい
これはフィロソフィーであって
フィロソフィー 哲学 ヴィジョン
知恵 ただの気持ちではありません
単純な 単純な気持ちには何も理屈はないでしょう
例えば人っていうのは
もうある あるカテゴリーの
例えばロック音楽好きですよと
それは理屈ではなくて
自分がただそれは好き
クラシック音楽は嫌い
それだけのことで そちらに気持ちだから理屈はないんです
哲学もないんです 野菜は生で食べるのは好きな人もいて
茹でて食べるのは好きな人もいます
それに何か哲学っていりません
ステーキ食べる時もいろいろあるでしょうね
レアかミディアムか生かどうしよう
生でいかん食べないでしょ
もう生でも食べますけど
まあ一応もういろいろ焼き方がありまして
だから別に何なのかと聞いてもあまり意味がないんですよ
なんであなたはレアでいいんですかと
なんであなたはミディアムのステーキ食べてるんですかと
もうその人は何かぺちゃぺちゃ言うんだけど
あんまり大した根拠はないんですよ
ミディアムの方が本当に美味しいんですって
レアの方が美味しくないはずでしょうに
そうするとレア焼きのステーキ食べない人間食べないでしょうに
そんなことないんだから
だからこの気持ちっていうのは哲学ではありません
理屈もない 論理ないんです
論理ないというのは論理は成り立たない
それは論理を探す必要はありません
あなたは何が好きですかと
それで終わり なんでなんでと聞く必要はないんです
あんた昼何にしますかと
じゃあもうラーメンにしますよ
あ そう じゃあラーメンにしましょう
それだけのことことで
なぜラーメンにするんですかと
それはラーメンの麺はもう一つに伸ばしちゃえば
まあ １キロになるんだから
どうかね 長さはとか そんな理屈なんね
今ないんですよ スープの中に入れてくれるんだからとか
それ理屈になりません
ご飯食べて別にスープ飲んだって同じことになりますからね
理屈で言えば 美味しいスープ付いてるんだからラーメン好きですよって言ったら理屈でしょ
だったらご飯食べてもっと美味しいスープ作って食べればいいでしょう
でもそうにはなりませんね
ラーメン食べたい人にはラーメンですから
ですから 何食べたいかで
それは気持ちですからね
それで ああそうですかと
ここで会話が終わっちゃうんです
それで気持ちの問題 それ
でも知ということは気持ちではなくて
あるヴィジョンであって
ヴィジョンっていうのは見方見解
だから死観なんです 哲学なんです
だから死の瞑想をする方々は
自分の人生に対する哲学自体が出来上がるかないかと
それをチェックしながら
この瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですよ
人生に対して 生きるということに対して
自分には違う見方 違う見解
違う哲学成り立ってくるでしょうかと
それはこの瞑想のチェックポイントなんです
それで結果でチェックする場合は
死の瞑想をする人々がしない人々より活発
死のことをごまかす人よりは元気
活発 明るい 行動的 それで性格はすごく滑らか
硬くない それでそれからもう一つ
誰ともぶつかろうとかね
張り合おうとかね そういうこともなくなっちゃうんです
すごくにこやかで 明るくて
ニコニコと 軽々く生きてるんです
それは結果 その結果 結果でも自分の瞑想が正しいかないかとわかるんですよ
瞑想していると どんどん硬くなって
暗くなって 小さくなって
やる気がなくなっていくと
あれは瞑想ではありません
ですから 死の瞑想はあの
まあ少々ややこしい瞑想なんです
ですが 初期仏教の方々っていうのは大体誰でも
やるんです 私の個人のことを言って申し訳ないんだけど
やっと外の世界の物事をわかってくるところで
母親が頭にたたき込まれたのは死ぬんだという概念なんです
みんな死ぬんだと なぜそのどんな時
その概念を叩き込んだというと
生まれた赤ちゃんがどんどん大きくなってきて
世の中が見えてくると
どんどん生きるぞというふうな欲のわがままな人格が出てくるでしょ
あれ欲しい これ欲しいと
くれなきゃ嫌だとか ものすごく泣いたりとかね
しゃがみ込んだりとか
一緒に歩く時 母親と何か自分が好きなものがあって
あれ欲しいと言ったらいいですよ
行きましょうと言ったらしゃがみ込むでしょ
子供たちはもう動かない
時々人の前でも 街の真ん中であろうが
ものすごい声で泣く これは 1 万人人が集められて
みんなに聞こえる泣き声
それで子供小さなもうお母さんにしたっても若くて普通の女の人だから
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
それで負けてはいわかりましたとか何とか言って
自分の欲しいものをあげたりする
そういうふうな どんな人間の性格もそういうふうにできちゃうんですよ
小さい時から 外の世界を見始めて
見え始めて認識し始めると
あれも欲しい これも欲しい
これは嫌 あれは嫌というふうな感じで出てくる
だから母っていうのは
まあ何だかんだでもサプライヤーですよ
子供に他の人がいないんだから
欲しいものだったらそちらに要求する
英語でサプライヤーと言うんですけど
日本で何と言いますか？何と言います？サプライ
供給  供給 供給 供給 供給
供給者と言えますか？日本語で
供給機関にでもしましょう
まあとにかくものをサプライする
供給する 自分のもう 機関はもう母親なんですね
だから欲しがるものを全部そちらに要求する
くれくれと  それで人間というのはそんな哲学知識を持っていないんだから
まあしょうがなくやってはあげますけど
まあ昔の人間だって 自分の母親はそれ
その時ですぐ頭に叩き込んだのは死ぬという概念なんです
それで必要なもの 欲しいものは何でもくれくれと言って
ものすごい嫌で嫌味で泣いたりしてね
こうもう母と喧嘩するっていうことは何のことなく消えちゃったんです
じゃあそれでもう三歳からもうその死ということを叩き込まれた私はすごく暗くて
勉強もしないで 人生は台無しになったかと
そうでもなかったんですけども
どんなとこでも負けず嫌いでとにかく勝ってやるぞという感じで生きてきたんだから
二番目にはなりませんと
教室でも勉強する時でも
勉強するんだったら結果は一番目に出すんだと
だから それは決して人の生き方に何か悪い影響を与えるわけじゃないんですね
で まあとにかく何のためにそんな話をしたんですかというと
この仏教の世界では一般的に誰でも死ぬんだということを教えてあげる
ですから この初期仏教を実践する人々とは話しやすいんですよ
商売でも何でも 人の意見
相談しやすいんです 人の意見も聞く
それで自分の意見だけ通ってほしいとも思わないんです
一応意見なんか組み合わせて
まあ曲げるところは曲げる
曲げてはいけないところはもうちゃんとこういうことですよとちゃんと言っておく
我が道一人で歩けっていうことはもうなくなっちゃうんですね
かなり柔らかくなります
心が うん まあとにかく
まあ死という死の瞑想っていうのはしなくちゃいけないことなんですね
だからそれ瞑想して 我々の心の中にこの書かれている
厳密に刷り込まれている私は死にませんという概念をもう捨てなくてはならないんですね
それで瞑想のやり方の場合は
あの はっきりした決まりがないんですね
私は死ぬ死ぬということで
あの 大体この思考を刺激するように瞑想するんですよ
ある経典持ってきましたけど
これはこの瞑想する場合は
生命すべてという一切の生命が死んでしまうんだというところから始まるんです
そこからの哲学でしょ
これスッタニパータの真理の言葉として訳されています
中村元先生 あの番番号振ってます
五七九という番号を振っている八番目の経典
もう一つありますけど
ちょっと時間なくて印刷できなかったんです
その経典の名前も面白い名前でサッラスッタなんですね
サッラっていうのはこの昔の戦いに行く時はこの長い人を刺す何か持っていくんですね
槍みたいなもの なんて言います
槍 槍持ってますよ それで敵を槍で刺すんでしょ
サッラっていうのは槍という意味なんですね
だから自分にも槍はもう刺されてるんですよ
槍が体に刺して向こう側まで行ったならば
もうどうなるんですかね
ほんのちょっと生きてるかもしれませんだけど
もう決まってるんですね
どうなるかということは
で 五七九から短い経典で五九八まであります
まあ少々この気持ちを理解できるためにちょっとだけ読みますけど
アニミッターンアナンニャータンマッチャーナンイダジービタンカシランチャパリッタンチャタンチャドゥッケーナサンユタン
もしパーリ語がわかる方々がいるならば
この経典を覚えて唱えればいいんです
すごい詩なんですよ で
アニミッターンアナンニャータン
もう決まりがない とても不確定であってわからないんだ
マッチャーナンイダジービタン
人間のこの世の中の命というものは不確定であって
あのあまり決まりませんと
カシランチャパリッチャンって
カシラン やっと生きてるだけやと
すごい苦労して生きてるんだと
パリッタン  そんな大した人生もできません
小さいんだと スモールパリッタンっていうのは
一人の人間の命っていうのは
ほんのわずかな小さなものだと
タンチャドゥッケーナサンユタン
その生きることもかなり苦しみで生きていなくちゃいけないんだと
ナヒソウウパッキャモアッティイエーナジャータナミッイェレジャランピパットワマラナンエーワンダンマヒパーニノ
こういうのは我々正式で使うんです
スリランカだったら正式で説法するんですよ
十五分ぐらい 二十分ぐらい
その説法なんかのタイトルにするのは
こういうだいたいこの経典なんです
私も覚えておかなくちゃ
まあ一応一応覚えてるんだけど
いくらか ナヒソウウパッキャモアッティイエーナジャータナミッイェレ
イエーナジャータナミッイェレ
生まれた人が見えないようにする
ウパッキャモ どんなからくりもない
ありません 生まれた人が死なない
死なないようにする 何か対策
方法 何かからくり 何もありません
ジャランピパットワマラナン
年取って死ぬんだと エーワンダンマヒパーニノ
生命の特色っていうのはそんなもんだよと
だから生命として見るんですよ
すべての生命 やっぱり死なないようにするという方法はありません
どんな生命でも年取って死んじゃうんだと
で 次 パラーナミワパッカーナン
パートーパタナトーバヤン
エーワンジャータナマッチャーナン
ニッチャンマラナトーバヤン
パラーナミワパッカーナン
木の実 木の実ですね もし熟したならば
黄色くなったならば パートーパタナトーバヤン
朝はもうないかもしれませんと
枝の先っぽに落ちるんだと
だからその当時で あの
あの 日本で黄色くなる果物といえばほとんど有名な一種ですね
あれ 柿ですか  柿は芽が強いんだからね
なかなか落ちませんだけど
で 黄色くなったらすぐ落ちる果物っていうのはいっぱいあるんですよ
インドにいっぱいあるのはマンゴなんですね
マンゴはあれ ついてるところ
すごく細いんですよ マンゴが黄色くなったらプチンと落ちるんです
だから熟したマンゴを食べたければ
マンゴの木の方に朝行けば下に落ちてるんですよ
落ちてるものは拾って
もうそのまま洗って食べられます
ちょうどいいところに熟しているんです
だからもういっぱいありましたから
あるんだから 今もインドでどこへ行ってもマンゴ
マンゴ マンゴばっかり見えますからね
マンゴーの黄身からなんとなく黄色いマンゴーを見たら
まあ汚いだろうと 落ちるんです
そのように果物が黄色くなったら落ちるんだよ
エヴァンジャーターのマッチャーナ
そのように人が生まれたら
生まれたならば ニッチャンマラナとばや
スーッと死ということがついているんだと
死ぬんだよと 生まれたらいつかわからない
スーッと過ぎているんだ
やたぴくんばカーラッサカタマッティカバージャーナサッベーベーダナパリアンタエヴァンマッチャーナジービタン
これも昔インドの周りを見て言ってる芸なんですよ
クンバカーラサっていうのは
この器を作る人 だいたい土で作るんですよ
普通の食器というか 料理用の皿と皿ではなくて
料理を作る鍋とかね 日本の土鍋みたいな
もう潰しても潰せないぐらい頑固で焼いて作るわけじゃないんです
だから日本の土鍋とあんまり一緒に考えないでください
素焼きというんですか
ただ土そのものを焼く
だからすぐ壊れる だからこの普通の土を練って入れ物を作って
クンバカーラっていうのはその仕事なんですよ
この土鍋を作る人はクンバカーラという
クンバカーラが作る鍋が
作った瞬間からもう壊れる可能性あるんだと
それから必ずしも壊れる
どれぐらい弱いというと
ちょっと石一つでもポチンと落ちたから穴が開けるんですよ
それぐらいもろいんです
今もずっと使ってます
そういうものは だからもう値段も安いし
厳密に温度を調整した
このあれ 何て言いますか
窯で焼く必要ないんだから
一旦作って それを積み重ねて
何かもう薪とかなんとか入れてただ燃やしちゃえばいいんです
それでいくらかは硬くなる
それでもって料理作ったりします
で 買ってきたものは何か水は漏れるようだったら捨てちゃって
他のものを買ってきます
あまり文句も言わない
すぐ壊れる場合もあるし
まあ壊れなかったら まあそれなりに 2
3年  4年  5年  10年使うものもありますけど
10年間使うと毎日毎日火の上にあるんだから
まあだから頑固硬くなったと
そうでもないんです それでも子供でも走ってたところにちょっと足に引っかかったらもう割れてるんですから
そういうふうにクンバカーラが作る
なんて言いますか こういう食器がすぐ壊れるように
人間の命も壊れてしまいます
ダハラチャマハンタチャ
イエーバラエーチェパンドイタサッビーマッチュワサンヤンティサッビーマッチュパラエナ
ダハラアカチャンでやろうか
マハンタ大人であるとか
バラ頭の良い人であるとか
パンドイタ賢者であるとか
サッビーマッチュワサン
みんな死にますよ サッビーマッチュパラエナ
みんなもう死で終わりますよと
テーサンマッチュパレターナンガッチャタンパラローコトナピタターヤテープッタンニャーティーワパナニャータケ
そのように死 もう必ずしも死んでしまう人々が死んであの世に行く時は
あの世に行った時は あの世に行かなくちゃいけない
それは単なる言葉で 死んだらあの世に行ったとね
他界しましたという言葉ですからね
で もう死ぬ運命の人々は他界するところでナピタタエテプッタン
お父さんにも自分の息子を守ることはできないんだと
例えば自分の息子が死んでいるんでしょ？死にかけているでしょ
いくら自分が父親だと言ったっても
どうすることもできないんだと
ニャーティーワパナニャータケ
あるいは自分にはすごい親戚がいるんだと思っても
親戚にも何もすることもできない
我が子は死にかけていると母親に守ってあげることもできないし
父親に守ってあげることもできないし
他の親戚に守ってあげることはできないでしょうと
ペッカンエーワニャーティーナンパッサララパタンプトゥ
エーカメーコーマッチャーナンゴーバッジョヴィエニーヤティ
ペッカンエーワニャーティーナン
親戚が待っているのに
例えば子供なんかの場合は
自分の母親 両親がもうそばに待っているのに
あるいは年取って死ぬ場合は
自分の子供たちやら他の親戚がみんな自分を囲んで待っているのに
パッサララパタンプトゥ
見てみなさいよと エーカメーコー
その人が一人で死ななくちゃいけないんだと
もうたとえで言えば ゴーバッジョヴィエニーヤティ
あの牛を屠殺すると この屠殺する人が牛を引っ張って連れて行くでしょ
そんな感じでこの人を引っ張って死へ連れて行かれるんだと
エヴァンアッバハトローコマッチュナチャジャラエチェタスマディーラネソーチャンティヴィリッットワローカパリアヤ
このように世の中悩ませている
悩んでいる 苦しんでいる
何に苦しんでますか？マッチュナエチェジャラエチェ
死ぬことと老いることで世の中は大変いじめられている
すべての生命が すべての生命はこの 2つで苦しんでいるんですよ
一切の生命が死と老いること
老死 老死っていうのは
まあ老死ではなくて あの
まあ老死 老と死というのはもう大変ないじめで
いじめ役で もう必ずもすべての生命を苦しませているんですね
タスマディーラネソーチャンティ
だから賢者が頭のいい人がネソーチャンティ悲しまない
そんなことを 別にみんなの運命だから悲しまないと
これは世の中の常であると
悲しむべきものではありませんと
ヤッサマッガンナジャナーシアガタッサガタッサワウボーアンテーアサンパッサンニラッタンパリデーワセ
ヤッサマッガンナジャナーシアガタッサガタッサワ
どこから来たか どこへ行ったか
さっぱりわかりませんと
わかりますか？我々はどこから来たんですかと
死んでからどこへ行くかと
どこから来たかもわからない
どこへ行ったかもわからない
さっぱりわからない この生命に対して両方わからない
ニラッタンパリデーワセ
泣くのは無意味だよと
自分の子供であるとどこから来たやつかわからないでしょうに
これで死んでからどこに行くかもわからない
なんで泣くんですかね
それで泣くのは無意味だよと
パリデーワヤマノーチェーキンチダッタンウダッバヘサモウローヒンサマッターナンカイラーチェーナンウィチャッカノー
もし人が死んだら泣くならば
泣き泣くことで何か得られるんだ
何か得するならばと 人が死んだらすごく泣く
泣くことで何か得するならば
何を得するんですかと
ただ苦れるだけ ただ苦れるだけだと
泣いて ナヒルンレーナソーケーナサンティンパッポーティチェータソー
そこで仏教の言いたいところがあります
ナヒルンレーナソーケーナ
すごい悲しんで泣くことでサンティンパッポーティ
心の安らぎは得られませんと
人が死んだところで悲しくて泣いて泣いて泣いて泣き崩れたところで何も得られません
そう泣き崩れると心の安らぎが得られませんと
ビーヤスッパッジャテドゥカン
ただ自分の苦しみがさらに増えるだけですよと
死んだのは他人なんですけど
残した人々はさらに苦しむ
それだけ 泣けば泣くほど苦しむだけでしょうと
で 体も壊せる壊れるんだと
だから自分が死んで自分の健康を失うことはバカバカらしいんだっていうことを言ってるんですよ
人が死んだってしても元気でやれと生きている者に言ってるんです
泣いて苦しむ必要はないんだと
キソーヴィワンノーババティヒンサマッターナマッターナナテーナペーターパーレンティニラッターパリデーヴァナ
泣くとキソー痩せちゃうんだと
これはいいことですよ
で まあこちらで痩せるっていうことはいい意味で言ってるわけじゃなくて
今の人々は食べ過ぎだからもう痩せるのはいいことなんですけど
あの健康を失うっていうことだからね
ヴィワンノーババティ
ものすごく醜くなるんですよ
泣いて泣いて もう消化もできなくて
体の体力もなくなって
体もほとんど醜くなる
それから精神的にヒンサマッターナマッターナ
自分で自分の心を苦しましてるんだと
ナテーナペーターパーレンティ
自分が泣いたんだからって
死んだ人には何の役にも立ちませんと
ペーターっていうのはこの餓鬼という言葉で訳しますけど
死んだ人々にはだいたいペーターという言葉を使ってますね
だから死んだ人に回向することは供養するとかは別なんですけど
泣いたんだからといって成仏できるわけでも何でもないんだと
全然死んだ人の役にも立ちませんと
ニラッターパリデーヴァナ
泣くことは無意味だよと
ソーカマッパジャハンジャントゥビーヨドゥッカンニガッジャティアヌットゥナントーカーラカタンソーカッサワサマンワグ
で 死ぬことで悲しむ 死ぬことで悩む
それは捨てない限りは
さらにさらに苦しめなくちゃいけない
だからどうせ生きることは苦しみでしょうに
その生きる上ではたくさん自分の親しい人々は死んでいくでしょうに
それにまた泣いて苦しんじゃうと
生きる苦しみは倍 3倍 4
倍 10倍になるだけですよと
アヌットゥナントーカーラカタンソーカッサワサマンガ
死んだ人のことを思い出して思い出して思い出して思い
思い出していること アヌットナっていうのはそういうことなんです
死んだ人のことを毎回毎回朝晩思い出しては思い出すとなる
そういうことでおって
ただ苦しみの奴隷になるだけ
悲しみの奴隷になるだけですよと
それでアンジェーピパスガミネヤタカンモーパゲーナレマッチュノーワサマーガッマパンダンテービダパーニノー
他の人々も見てみなさいよと
世の中を見てみなさいよ
いろんな人が死んでるでしょう
どんな生命でも 動物でも
いっそでもこの触れて触れているんだと
何に触れているの？死の恐怖感で
動物でも餌取りながら怖がっているでしょ
鳥見たっても 餌取りながら周り見たりと
あれ 殺されるかないか見ているんですよ
落ち着いて食べることもできないんですよ
動物には 人間にはできますけど
でも戦争があったりすると落ち着いて食べられないでしょうに
1年前のボスニアやらそういうところにしたっても
今もいろんなところで
まあ落ち着いて寝ることもできない
もうどこから爆弾をかけてくるかわかりませんだから
ですから 動物の世界を見ても
他の世界を見てくださいよと
みんないつでも震えているんだと
死で イエナイエナヒマンニャンティタトタンホーティアンジャタエーターディソーヴィナーバオパッサローカッサパリヤーヤン
で ここでまたある哲学なんですよ
世の中の有様見なさいよと
パッサローカッサパリヤーヤン
世の中の有様見なさいよ
イエナイエナヒマンニャンティ
何か何か思ったら こうなりたい
ああいう風になりたい
このようになりたいと思ったら
タトタンホーティアンジャタ
全く反対のことになるんだと
思うことが全く逆になってしまっちゃいますよと
例えば美しくなりたいと世の中に売っているお化粧品はね
まあ使い放題使っちゃどうなるんですかね
皮膚が荒れて 結局生まれつきの皮膚が病気になってしまうでしょ
トカゲの皮膚のようになるんです
私はもう何人か見たんですよ
皮膚はすごい綺麗なまあ女優さんなんでしたけど
で まあちょっと何十年前の話
まあニコニコといろいろ喋ってはしましたけど
ちょっと近寄るなよっていう気持ちがあるんですよ
もう大変 日本で有名な女優さん
でもまあいい 親しく喋れません
近寄るなよと なんだか皮膚はトカゲの皮膚ではないかという感じがするんですよ
で なぜかというと あれ
お化粧塗りすぎ 塗りすぎ
塗りすぎで 映画なんかにテレビドラマなんかに出なくちゃいけないんだから
この光を反射して綺麗に映してもらうために塗って塗って
そこら辺ちょっとでももう落としてみちゃったら
もう皮膚の状態っていうのは大変なんですよ
まあだからまあそれは余計な話でね
哲学的な話ではないんだけど
一応哲学的に言えば世の中の有様を見てみなさいよと
人が何か何か希望すると
結果は全く逆で もう全く違う結果になるんじゃないんでしょうかと
エーターディソーヴィナーバオ
そのようにすべてなくなっちゃうんだと
それから人間は一番希望するものは死なない
死なないこと それははっきりと裏切られるんです
死ぬんだと ラッセルアピヴァッササタンジーヴェビーヨワパナマナゴニャーディサンガーヴィナーホンディジャハティダジービタン
もし人が頑張って頑張ってワッササタンジーヴェ100年間生きていたとすると
えっと ビーヨワパナ あるいは100年以上も生きていたとしたらどうなるかというと
自分には誰もいなくなっちゃうんだと
だからこの100歳飛んじゃったら
自分の奥さんはいない
子供も死んでるとか 一緒に学校に行った人々
一緒に本当に自分に親しい仲間たち
親戚はいないんですよ
孫 ひ孫いたってもね 全然もう知らんですからね
そういう人々は 後から来た人だから
そんなに親しみ感じません
だから長生きしちゃったらどうなるかと
一人ぼっちになるんだと
他の人は死んでしまいますから
タスマアラハトゥスットワヴィネイヤパリデービタンペータンカーラカタンディッスワネーソーラブバーマヤーイティ
それでアラハトスットワ
悟った人々に聞きなさいよ
聞いてヴィネイヤパリディーリタ
死に対して悩むことをなくなくそう
人が死んだんだからといって悩むなかれと
泣くなかれよと 聖者たちの悟った人々の話を聞いてみなさいよと
ペータンカーラカタンディスワネーソーラバーマヤイティ
死んだ人を見て これをどういう風に訳せばいいかな
死んだ人を見ると まあこれっきりで
その人はもう私たちのものではないんだと
もう死んじゃった人も終わったよと
時々人が泣くと 私の息子はどこへ行ったんでしょうかとか
まあインド文化だったらね
まあ帰ってくれとかね
どこへ行ったんでしょうとか
そういうふうな泣き言葉もありますよ
それについて言ってるかもしれません
日本の方々 どのような風かわかりませんだけどね
で ですから これ インド的な泣き方かもしれませんし
ですから 死んだ人を見たら
じゃあまあ帰ってくるわけじゃないんだと
もう行っちゃったと もう終わったと言って落ち着いてみましょうと
ヤタサラナマディッタンワーリナパリニバエ
エーバンピディーローサッパンニョパンディトグソロナラキッパンウッパティタンソーカンワトートゥーランヨダンセー
で もし何か火が燃えていると
我々はさっと水をかけてそれを消す
そのように智慧のある人が
上手な人が 心に死に対して悩みが生まれたらすぐ消しなさいと
泣いたり またいろいろ文句言ったり
なんで早く死んだんだろう
なんで早く逝ったんだろうとか
私一人残して なんであんた一人？そういうふうなことを思ったりするでしょうに
そういうことを思ったりして
自分を暗く暗くするならば
それであなたは幸せになりませんと
あなたはさらにこの矢で
嫉妬やで あなたはさらにさらにきつく刺されるだけですよと
それでどうしますか？と
アッブルサロー この矢を抜けましょう
死ぬのは嫌だということな
その場合は 死ぬのは嫌だということがあると
もう矢に刺されていますよ
苦しみになるんです 死ぬのは嫌だと思ったら
ですから 死ぬのは嫌だというこの矢を抜けましょう
サンティンパップイエチェーテソ
心を安らげなしなさいよと
サッバルカンアティッカンと
世の中の状況を乗り越えましょう
アソーコーホーテニブト
まあ来る悲しみがない
ニブタでは涅槃のことを落ち着きという言葉ですけどね
心の落ち着き 心の安らぎを体験しなさいと
だからこれは死の瞑想なんですよ
だから結構違うでしょ
死を 死の見方 哲学的に見ているんです
感情的に見ているわけじゃないんです
論理的に見ているんです
人が死んで泣くんだったら
あんた損するんだと 泣いて何が得られるかと
あんた苦しむだけですよ
そういうふうに見て瞑想
もう一つの瞑想のやり方ありまして
この例えばロウソクの炎があってもいつ消えるかわからない
例えば外でロウソクを一つ立てておくと
どこから風が吹くかわからないでしょうし
いつ風が吹いてくるかわからない
そのように私の命もいつ死ぬかわからないんだよと
風が吹いてきて死ぬかもしれません
ろうそくだから あるいは倒れてろうそくの炎が消えるかもしれません
風が吹かなくたっても
ろうそくのろうが消えたところで消えてしまいますからね
命っていうのはそのようなものだと
それから石一つ二つ割ったならば
また二度と戻らないように
もう確実に死んじゃったらまた戻ってくると
この世で生き返るということもありませんと
それで 水の上に書いた絵のごとく
書くと同時に消えてしまいますね
そのように人々っていうのは生まれたら確実に死んでしまうんだと
命は稲妻のように短いんだと
それで弓から放った矢が戻ることないんだと
先に行って落ちるんだと
そのように生まれた人には死を迎えていくしか方法ないんだと
そういうふうに この死に対して哲学的にこれは一般的なものだというふうに見るんです
当たり前だ 常識だ 何のこともないんだ
当たり前のことに常識なことはニュースにもならない
例えば 明日の新聞で大スクープだ
今日は日曜日だと出ますか？タイトルなんかは
出ませんで当たり前だから
明日日曜日ということはスクープでも何でもないんです
あるいは明日 大スクープだ
今日は太陽がもう何時何分かわかりませんだけど
もう太陽が出ましたとかね
毎日のことだから もう当たり前だから
そういうものはニュースにならないんですよ
ニュースになるのは お母さんが子供を殺したとかね
そういうありえないと思うものはニュースになります
びっくりもします 何だろうかと
例えば日本でどこかのコンビニに強盗が入ってお金を持って行ったら
それはニュースになります
もし毎日どこかでコンビニがやられるんだったら
全然ニュースにならないんです
だからびっくりするものじゃないんです
みんな死ぬんだという
この我々は認めたくない
この事実を心でとにかく頑張って認める
認めて落ち着く あ そう死んだの
それぐらいで まあ私も後から来るんだからと
まあまあ そんな大したことはないと
みんなの運命だと そこにもう神様の話やら仏様の話やら
もう迎えに来る話やら
どんなまあもうSF映画みたいなね
話は持ってくる必要はないんだっていうのは
初期仏教の見方なんです
それは死に対するアプローチなんですね
それで自分には死の実感ないんだから
当たり前だからね 死んだ
面白いことって 自分が死んだことは一度もないのに
死ぬのは怖い怖いと言うでしょ
死ぬのはやっぱり怖いんだと
これはもう死んだこともないのによくも言うんですからね
なぜそう言うんですか？と頭に死にませんよということが書かれているでしょう
書かれているんだけど
死ぬかもしれませんなと思っちゃったら怖くなるんですよ
ですから 死なないということは消した方がいいんですね
それは正しい見方になります
すごい明るい哲学も生まれてきます
明るい生き方 明るい世界というものは生きてきて出てきます
見方がものすごく変わるんです
で  これは死の瞑想についてなんですけど
で どうしますか このターミナルの問題にちょっと触れたいんですけど
えっと ちょっと休憩 疲れていらっしゃるならば
ちょっと10分ぐらい休憩にして後半に行きます
じゃあそれでは後半に入ります
で 後半に入る前にもう一つ
あの死に対してどの自分の死に対してどのように瞑想するかという場合は
このよく他人の死を観察する
いくらでもこの世の中で
人であろうが動物であろうか
死んじゃいますよ いくらでも見えるはずなんです
魚屋さんに行ったっても見えるでしょうに
死体は見えないというならば
築地ですか そちらへでも見学にでも行ってみれば
どれぐらい死んでるかと
と見えるでしょう 見たら人間というのは全く非論理的なことを考える
このマグロはまあおそらく
500万円だよとかね
これはすごい美味しいですよとかね
そういうものすごい残酷なことばっかり考える
どれぐらいお金になるかとかね
そういう考え方はもう無知的な考え方で
知恵の哲学的な見方じゃないんですね
だから仏教で死の瞑想したい人々にこの一言葉を教えているんですよ
ヤタエータンカタイダンという言葉覚えておいてください
あの これはあの 一つのまた瞑想の言葉なんです
私は誰かが死んだことを見る
見たらヤタエータン ヤタエータン
これは どのようになったか
ただ そのようにイダンこれも
ただそれだけ なかなか英訳もできないんですよ
なぜならば動詞もない
ただ言葉 4つだけ でもパーリ語だったらそれで意味がちゃんと通じる
エータンというのは これはイダン
それは前にあるもの イダンというのは
これはということ これそれこれって意味なんです
それはどのようになったか
これもそのようになるんだと
だから自分が例えばこの誰かのね
亡くなったら行くでしょ？行ったら遺体見たらいろんなことをくだらんことを言うんじゃなくて
あ それはとこれはと思えば
それぐらいのことだよ
それはこのまあ このようになった
そのようにこれもこの体もなるんだと
それは死の瞑想の仕方なんです
だからこのバカでかい
あれ 何でしたか？あの魚
このマグロ 見たら これはまあすごいいいもので
もう 1,000万円ぐらいの価値があるんじゃないかなとかね
まあという思うんじゃなくて
まあそれは今どのようになっているかとも死んで死体になっていると
これからぶつ切りにして競りに出して
もうみんな買って食べるんだと
まあこれは食べるわけじゃないんだけど
もう誰も食べてくれませんだけど
まあこれもそのようになるんだと
特に人間死んだらまた必ず同じことでしょう
もう燃やすか埋めるかと
あ こちらもそのようになるんだと
ですから 日本風に言えば
私も死ぬんだという一言葉でいいんです
それは死んだ時観察するんですよ
だからすごいクールなんですよ
死に死体に対してアプローチが感情的じゃないんです
それはもうなかなか まあしょうがないんですけど
あまり美しく すごい感情的で
歌を流しながら葬式やるとかね
そういうのはないんですね
あんまり すごくクールで淡々と日常茶飯事のことのように遺体を処理する
それだけ 仏教の見方はね
ですから もう自分の知ってる親しみの人々が死んじゃったら
必ず皆様が参加する そちらには行ったら
なんで早く死んだだろうとかね
天国に見守ってくださいとかね
そういうのはもう嘘の世界で根拠ない
ただ人間の慰めだけ 気休めの言葉だけなんですね
死体の前で論文書いて持っていって
論文というか 作文か持っていって読むと
ああいうのはもう文化的にやってますけど
哲学的に別に何か仏教哲学的に何も意味があるわけじゃないんですね
まあ時々葬式 その遺体がある時にやる場合もあるし
1ヶ月後で写真と位牌だけ入れてやる場合もあるですので
もう位牌の前で 写真の前で
なんとか人の名前を読んで
あなたはなんとかなんとかとか
もうそのどんな言葉で言うんですか
その場合は え？弔辞 弔辞の言葉言いますけど
それはもう勝手に遊びですからね
どんな遊びでもよろしいですけど
それは遊びだけなんですよ
遊びだと思ったら私も認めますよ
例えば ある人が死ぬ時
私にはもう火葬する時はこの曲で曲を流してあげてくださいと言うならば
まあじゃあ気持ちよくやりましょうというならばいいんですよ
遊びだったら それ以上意味があると思ったら困るんですね
弔辞も まあ自分たちの文学能力を出すところやと思って
そこを競い合ったっても構いませんだけど
死んだ人に何の役にも立ちません
まず ですから 遊びだったらいいんですけど
それ以上のことを考えてはいけません
それで この死の瞑想っていうのは
私もこのようになる この体もこのようになると言って
ほんのちょっと自分の死もほんのちょっとイメージをしてみる
で すごい変化がわかるんです
私は一回事故を起こして人が死んで
その見たんだけど 死んだ時ではなくて
もう遺体はもうとっくに運ばれてあったんだけど
で ほんのちょっと一部脳細胞やと脳だと思い
脳みそやと思いますけど
ほんのちょっと見えたんですね
道路に残っていて それ見えた瞬間で
まあある若者が今死んだだろうと
ということは すぐもう
なんとなく体に入っちゃって
そこであの脳みその一部見たら
これにはもう今命も何もない
いかに命っていうのは儚いで
瞬時に消えるものでしょうと言った途端
それは自分の命になったんですよ
今 その時もいっぱいこのファイルを持って
重いカバンを持って大学に講義があります
その講義をするために行った途中なんですよ
あまりもうバスが止まっちゃったんですね
もうそこら辺で止まったところで
窓から見ただけなんですけど
そこで自分たちがもう張り切って生きるために
もうやってる この生き方はいかに儚いで
いかに瞬間で全て消えるかということをパッと入っちゃって
なんか体からあったいろんなもう汚れのようなものというか
この執着のようなものはサッと消えて
もう何もない世界がその瞬間に生まれちゃうんですね
だから欲もないし 怒りもない
その代わり何かあるかって
何でもない やっぱり命っていうのはそんなものやと
だからその人によってインパクトはね
それぞれ違いますけど
もう一回私にあったのは
一緒に大学に勉強していた同じ年のある若いお坊さんが死んじゃったんですね
白血病で で 大学卒業して年目か年目かと思います
だから歳も同じで もうみんな歳代でしょ
その人のお寺に行って
もう何も仕切りもしないで
私はただ遺体の前でこういうふうに手を組んで見たんですけど
同じ年だからね もうそちらにその人がいないんですよ
ただ遺体だけ やっぱりなんか見方がえらい違うんだよ
私の見方が 私はそこに自分の死を置き換えて見る
それは死の瞑想なんだ
だから小さい時からもうやっと言葉なんかわかるようになってきたところで
もう叩き込まれちゃったんだから
どうしてもそうなっちゃうんですね
遺体見ちゃうと 悲しいとかということでもないんです
なんで死んだんだろうとかね
そういうことでもないし
当たり前のことでしょうし
だから自分も別にそういう状況から離れてるわけじゃないんだと
だから瞑想するようなことは
やたえたんたたいだんという言葉なんですね
これはどのようになっているか
そのようにこれもなるんだといって
この常識に持ってくるんですよ
本当の常識に 死ということは
自分の死の実感はないんです
自分死ぬ時一回きりだから
だから死を見るたびに
まあ私も死ぬんだから
私も死ぬんだから ただそれだけ
だから人間の死を見た方が一番よろしいんですけど
もう何見たら 例えばよくあるでしょと
子供がすごく可愛がっていた犬か猫が死んじゃったら
子供は泣いたりする それで親がまあ天国に行ったんだから
天国にいてあなたのことをじーっと待ってる
見ているんだからね 大丈夫やとか
あんな嘘なんで言うんですかと
とにかく子供を慰めるためにいろいろごまかしを
もう天国で待ってるんだとかね
じっとそばにいるんだとかね
死んでもとかね だから大丈夫や
心配する必要はないんだとかね
そうじゃなくて 本当に言った言うべきなのは
みんな死ぬよ 君も死んじゃうよ
泣いたってもワンちゃんだからまあ歳で死んじゃうし
あんた人間だから まああとそろそろまあ年ぐらい経ったら死ぬでしょう
その前でも事故を起こしたりとかね
もう何かもう何かちょっと階段から足を滑ったりして
でもまあ死ぬかもしれませんよというふうに言ったら泣かないんですよ
なんでそれやらないかと
事実でしょうし だから子供っていうのは小さい時はすごい
この真理を教えてくれると大人も信頼するんですよ
子供 子供に我々はすごい嘘を教えるでしょ
だからまあ それなくて
単なる事実をそのまま言っちゃうと
子供はそうとわかってもわからなくても
事実を言ったら納得するんですよ
あんたわかったかって
これはまた別な話で で
あの 例えば私はどこから来たんですか？こうのとり持ってきたんだよというのはとんでもない話なんですね
だから若者たち ばれないよと
あんたはこちらから生まれたんだからと
だからわからないかもしれませんだけど
それは事実だから 子供はその時落ち着いちゃうんですね
ですから 子供にでもあんな変なことじゃなくて
事実そのまま言っちゃえばいいんです
だって子供は死ぬのは嫌だと
嫌と言ったってもどうしようもないでしょうにと
何言うんだよ このバカと言っちゃえば
当たり前の事実だとすぐわかってくれるんですよ
だから この仏教の世界と普通の信仰を重んじている世界の差がそちらにあるんですね
我々は何のことなく事実そのものを言っちゃう
そこで我がないしにわがままもないで
ない性格で謙虚的ですぐ頑張る人間にはなります
そこ そういうことだから
まあ当たり前 どうしたことないという
この明るい見方 仏教で今の前説明した経典でもなくない
泣くのはバカだよということを言っていたんだから
泣いてあんた得するのはただ疲れることだけですよと
さらに体苦しむれるだけですよ
みんな死んじゃうんだと
泣くことによって心の落ち着きが出てこないんだということだから
いつでも我々は朝太陽が出てびっくりする人がいないし
あの 何も普通のことに何一つびっくりしないでしょ
たまたまどこかで地震が起きたなかで
そんなにびっくりもしませんし
で ごく普通にいるんだからね
そういう感じで それぐらい死ということは当たり前のことだから
まずびっくりしないこと
驚かないこと 心の落ち着きを守ることはすごく必要なんです
ですから 死の瞑想は一番やるべき時期は若い時なんです
年取ってくると もうあまりにも長い間騙されて
もうもう馬鹿げた生き方で生きてきたんだから理解できないんですよ
あまりにも頭が悪すぎて
ですから このできるだけ早いうち
死ぬ だから私はみんなに遠慮しちゃうんですね
死の瞑想なんかは もう遅いんじゃないかなと
で 子供なんか聞いたらすぐ教えるんです
死って何なのかと で 頭にはちゃんと入ります
できるだけ若い時やった方がいいんです
で あの 危険なところもありますから
例えばこのもう歳のおばあちゃん
おばあさんはこれから死の瞑想なさいと言ったら
おばあちゃんにとっては目の前の事実だから
高齢者血が混乱する おばあちゃんがもうせっかく極楽堂に行き生きようかなと思っていたところでね
あの心の落ち着くはなくなるかもしれませんし
ですから どんなものを瞑想にしたっても
やっぱり時期とまあそこありますからね
向き不向きもありますし
まあ年によってもあるし
大体仏教の中でもこの若い人々を元気な時
すごい体力があって自信満々の時は死の瞑想とくとんしてみて
あのわがまま高慢を飛ばしちゃうんですね
で より立派な落ち着いている人間になる
それからわかりやすい言葉で言うのは
こういうことを言いたいんです
赤ちゃんなんかは 母親がちょっと手で顔を隠して
いない いない いないと言っただけで笑うでしょ？いないわけでも何でもないのに
ものすごく笑っちゃうんですね
手も足も動かしながら
だから 死ぬ時もそれぐらい笑って死んでほしい
明るく で 赤ちゃんは別に何も
一般的にはそれほど悩みも何もあるわけじゃないし
じっと母親そばにいるし
安心しているし だから笑える
物事は当たり前だと思ったら安心できるでしょうに
で 昔の人間みたいに女流になってから
原始時代で人々が聞いた話なんですけど
いたわけじゃないんだから
あの 太陽が沈むとお祈りするんです
もし明日出てこなかったら大変だから
どうか我々の罪を許して
明日もおいでになってくださいと
と神様にお祈りする それでぴったしお祈りを聞いて
次の日も太陽が現れるんですよ
もっと不思議なのは こちらから沈んだ太陽が全く違う方向から出てくるんだから
これは不思議でたまらなかったんですね
昔の人にとっては で 今は日の出を見て拝む人はいるんだけど
もうあれは原始時代からね
咲いている遺伝子のあれだと思いますけどね
まあ一応感動しますね
で 私はすごい綺麗だから
あ すごい綺麗だなと なんと美しいやと思う時ありますけど
で 私は自分の国は西の方にいるんだから
日の出よりは西没はよく見るんですよ
それで海の中に太陽が入っちゃうと
ものすごいもう美しいんです
で 向こうは暑い国だからね
もう空の空にかける色の数々っていうのは
もうすごい もう言えないほど綺麗なんですけど
ですから まあそれはそれで
今はあまりごく普通の当たり前のことで
ですから 日の出やら日没やら
まあごく普通の当たり前のような感じで
人の生まれも死もまあ同じ当たり前のことだと見ること
理解すること その角度で見ること
人が生まれたら ああ もう万々歳で喜んじゃうでしょうに
同じ気持ちで人死ぬ時もいなくてはならないんです
だから言えないんですけど
おばあちゃんいいですね
こんなもう早く死ねるんだから
もうこんな嫌な体 もうこれで終わりますからね
嫌なことも嫌な出来事もいろんなことをもうこれでもう置いておくんだからね
楽でよかったと だからこれは言ってはいけません
それはまあ どうせ仏教の世界でもそんなことは言いません
でも一応理解するために
そんな感じで死も見なくちゃいけないの
決して暗いものではないんだ
当たり前のことなんです
その目で我々はこのターミナルケアであろうか
この末期的な病気にかかっている人々に面倒を見る時も
その心なんです 必要なのは
その心でやるならば 私は何の説教をする必要もないんです
これ ごく普通 常識 当たり前のことで
それ社会問題ではありません
ニュースに出るぐらいのことじゃないんですよ
国会で延々と議論するものじゃないんです
なんで今それ延々と議論するんですかね
当たり前のごく普通のことだから
そんなものはもう国会なんか始めた時も決めた方が良かったのに
1946年です といた方が良かったのに
だって普通のことでしょうに
人が年取ってもう寝たきりになったりして
後で死んじゃいますよと
治らない病気はあるんだよということは
今更発見したんですかね
やっぱり末期がんになったらどうしようかとよく考えること
末期がんみたいなもう治らない病気っていうのは
今今最近の出来事だったらニュースなんですけど
それだったら国会でも議論するわ
いろんなところで議論するということはいいんだけど
いかに人間は事実から離れて引っかかるでいいかということなんですね
新しく 21 世紀で人間の大変大問題
老化問題とか何おっしゃってますかと
そんなことは人類が現れて以来あることで
だから仏教の見方っていうのは
その目で見る まず 当たり前だと
何のこともないんだと
そんなことに準備してないんだったら
バカもいいところだと
我々はこの玄関に鍵か鍵かけるの忘れちゃったらものすごく怒られるでしょ
あんたもうなんでそんなにボケてるんですか？とか
ちゃんと気をつけて玄関に鍵でもかけなさい
どうでな でも別に玄関に鍵かけなかったんだからって言って泥棒入るわけないでしょうに
で そういうことは当たり前だと言ったりする
私は別にあんまり当たり前だと思っちゃわないんですね
鍵かけ忘れちゃったら
あっ 鍵かけ忘れちゃったなと思うだけ
それで部屋に入ってみたら
あ 泥棒も入ってないんだと
だから別にどうったことはなかったと
それで鍵かけ忘れて家に入ったら泥棒入ってきたな
なるほど 鍵をかけ忘れたんだから泥棒入ったんだと
当たり前だと思っちゃうんです
そうすると心の落ち着きはすーっとあるでしょうに
それで人が末期状態になったら
このこのターミナルのその間では
我々はその人の面倒を見なくちゃいけない
本人には自分のことを見ることできませんだからね
その時はまあごく普通に元気な時もお茶入れてあげたし
ご飯も作ってあげたし
そんな気持ちで じゃあじゃあご飯食べますか
今日はとかね そんな感じで見ればすごい楽なんです
自分は大体この人がなかなかあまり経験はないんだけど
あの 何人かね 病気になっても面倒を見なくちゃいけない時になった時は
あまりにも当たり前でやっていたんですね
じゃあどうします？ご飯なんですけど
ご飯食べる？とか 薬なんですけど
ご飯食べる前に 30分前に薬飲まなくちゃいけないんですけど
だからごく普通な顔で
そうしながら私は私の人生で遊んだり
いろんなことをやったりする
そこでお世話してもらう人にとっては
もう想像を絶するリラックスするんですよ
何もわがままにあ ご飯ですか
じゃあじゃあ食べますとかね
言って 自分で食べられないんだったら食べさせてあげたりするだけで
あ 大変だとかね 一言葉も言わないんです
あ びっくりしましたとかね
で 私は出家された大長老がもう 3ヶ月間くらい病気でいろいろ治療していたんだけどね
で もっと体力もあった
上年上のお坊さんたちがいたんだけど
薬飲まないんですよ あげると
長老みんなこのあまりにも偉い長老だから何か言いたく言えないんです
怖くて怖くて そこで俺
トラブル起こったりするし
長老ももうみんなに叱ったりもするし
で 長老に怒られるのはみんなすごい怖がってるし
それで私は一応面倒を見ることに
自分勝手にもう勝手に始めたんですね
他の人々はいろんな薬を作ってくる
私はまあチェックして
3時の薬や 6時の薬とか見てて
先生のところに先生 まあ 3時の薬ですけど
あ そう じゃあちょっと起こしてくれ
それだけ で 私は起こしてあげる
それでもう薬を取って
すごくもうすごいもう私に対しても愛情いっぱい
それで私からもすごい愛情が生まれてくるんですね
もうなんの文句も言わないで
このすごい偉大なる人物が何のことに
あ そうじゃん 起こしてくれ
で 起こしてあげる それで薬を取って飲む
で 口を洗う 口を洗うんだから
水というと ちゃんと手のところに水がある
水を飲んで口も洗って
また横にしてあげる  ね
で その間に何かあったら何かしてあげるんだけど
またはどこかに走っていって
何かもう若い頃でしたからね
いろいろみんなからかったり遊んだりも
まあそれもしている それも長老にも聞こえるし
外行って遊ぶ時間がなかったら
その前でもう他の同じ年の人と喧嘩したり
いろいろことをやり合ったりもする
全然怒りも何もしない
あんまりにも当たり前でやってるんだから
で 一回私はなんかできなくて
何か他のことにやっていて手が空けなかったんですね
そこで私の上の長老が薬を作って持って行ったんですね
持って行ってんだけど
大長老からいろんな質問されるわ
されるわ まあなかなか大変なんですね
これは6時の薬ですか？と
はい そうでございますけど
じゃあちょっと調べてみなさいと言って
また調べてるとたくさん薬のリストあったんだから
どちらどちらそれで不安になっちゃうんですね
薬間違ってるんではないかと
ね あんたね これちゃんと調べて確認してから持ってくるものではなく
それで言われるんですよ
で 確認していないということは
本当は確認しているんですね
作る時は で この長老もちゃんと確認して持って持ってきているのに
わがままを言わないで飲んでくれという気持ちなんですよ
なんでそんなに今 その時
その長老ももう 60歳でしたと思いますけど
お世話した長老もこんな年になって
いまだに私にいろんなわがままを言うという気持ちな大人だから
で 薬飲まなかったんで
そこでまあ 私の仕事は
私はものすごく走って
まあ子供なんでしたからね
もう何のことなく ガタガタガタガタと走って部屋に行ったところで
長老もお手上げ状態で
薬は飲まないし 私はまあなんでしょうかね
じゃあまあ この私に言ったら
なんか長老の薬ですけど
あ そう じゃあ私持ち上げますと言って
私は先生 これは3時の薬ですけど
ああそう じゃあ何のことない
じゃあ起こしてくれと
すぐ問題が解決しました
だから亡くなる瞬間までも
私といろんな話をしながら
まあいろいろ話 もういろんな
もう何て言いますか 死ぬ時はいろんなね
もう幻覚みたいなものを見えたりするでしょうしね
それはもう言ったりする
私は知ってるんだから
他の人々はもうわからないんだから
変なことを言う 長老の気に入らないんで
そうするといろんな幻覚
たまたま見えてあっても
ちゃんと知識あって ちゃんともうしている人だから
私は何のことなくそれに付き合う
ああ そうですか 一回言ったのは
この上にも何か乗せているんではないかと
その時 病院の上何か乗せているんではないかと
これ倒れてきたら大変だよと
何か見えてるんですよ
私は ああ そうね ああ これ大丈夫です
これは落ちませんね で言ったら
ああそう ああそうですか
それで落ち着くん ただそれだけ
また一回 なんで自転車こちらに置いてるんですかね
これ落ちるかもしれませんよ
何か見せて言うんですね
そしたらえ？え？これ落ちませんよ
先生 これは落ちません
ちゃんと入れてますと
で ベッドから動けないんですけど
ずっと 24 時間にして
一人ずっと面倒を見るために待っていたんです
で それいきなりもう外へ行きたいと
で これ 2 日間その喧嘩あったんだけど
まあ交代もしますから
他の長老たちはこの問題をむちゃくちゃにしちゃって
で 外へ行ってと言っても
行けませんよと もうベッドにいなくちゃいけませんよとか言われて
これ認めない長老がとにかく外へ行きたいんだと
で 私がベッドのそばへ行ったら
ちょっと外へ行きたいんだけど
だから私はあー でも雨が降ってますよ
何のことなくなんかやんとなんかパラパラと雨が降ってますよと
あ そう じゃあ風邪引いちゃいますからね
それで風邪引いちゃいますからね
だから この亡くなるその時までそうやって
ごく普通に もう当たり前で
もう何のことなく面倒を見て
かなりもう楽でした 私はほとんど 3ヶ月近くもう寝たことは覚えてないんだけど
それで最終的には 1週間ずっともうもう 1 分も寝ることができなかったんだけど
全然もう体疲れたわけでも何でもなく
もう楽しかったんですよ
だから亡くなる時もいきなり戦争発作が出てきて
私の手を握ったんだけど
なんでこんなに力あるんですか？私はものすごい信じられなかったんですね
こんなに年取っているのに
その瞬間で もしかするとそんなに力あるんだったら
やっぱり元気になるかもしれませんという余計な希望も出たんだけど
やっぱり元気になったところじゃなくて
そのまま息を止め止めちゃったんですね
息を止めた瞬間で 私はあ
私の仕事も終わったと
その瞬間が私の仕事が終わったと
それで行って 隣のお寺に行って
いっぱいご飯を食べて寝ちゃったんです
仕事終わったと 別にもうすごい悲しかったんだけど
もうそれはもう後でゆっくりゆっくりと
やっぱり長老が亡くなったんだって思い出すと悲しかったんですけど
正直なところ だからこのターミナルケアっていうのはごく普通
当たり前のことだから
当たり前のことで見なくちゃいけない
当たり前のことだと見たら
もう何も言うことはなく
ものすごい簡単にできるんですね
例えば もう寝たきりの人がもう同じように
歩きたいと言ったならばね
じゃあ歩いてみる？と言ってみればどうですかね
いちいちおせっかいしないで
じゃあ歩いてみる？で
私は手を出しませんよ
それぐらいのことで まあなんとかうまくいくんです
なんとかうまくいくんです
それから一番問題になるのは
例えばがんとかになって
すごい頭がしっかりしている
歩ける で 健康的な人々
この末期状態なんですけど
他の問題はない そのホスピスなんかのところにいる人々の場合はね
で 喋られる 話すこともできる
新聞も読める テレビも見られる
そこら辺散歩もできる
その人々の場合は 体のことは別に
まあそういう状態だから自由でしょうし
まあその人々とはいろんなことをしゃべり
しゃべったらいいんですね
何をしゃべるかというと
そのポイント大事なんですよ
例えば我々はしゃべりたがる
希望するのは もしかするとね
もう超能力でも神様の神様の力でもあって
病気治ったらありがたいですよとかね
そういうSF的な話はしたがる
考えたがるんですけど
そうではなくて いつでも事実をしゃべるんですね
例えばそういう人がね
まあもう私が死ぬんだからね
もう財産のことは会社なんですけどね
もうこの子供たちにはちゃんとやれるかどうか
ちょっとわからないんだとかね
そんなくだらんことを考えたってもね
意味がないでしょうと
どうせ死ぬ時はね そんなものを置いておくんだから
後から何やるかと誰にも管理できないでしょうに
そんなものが潰れたっても
どうったことないでしょうにと
子供たちがもし会社を倒産させたったら
それはそちらの問題でしょうにと
あんた それ持っていくつもりですか？と
そうやってちょっと失礼そうに聞こえる事実を語ればいいんです
ある長老が突然 ちょっともう熱を出して病気になって
もういきなり体が震え始めて怖くなったんだよ
その人が で もしかすると死ぬかもしれませんと
今まで死ぬっていうことは考えたことなかったんですね
だから用意しなくちゃいけないこといっぱいあるんですね
死ぬ前にという でお寺のことはどうしますか？もう弟子たくさんいたんだから
その人はどうしますか？あの人はどうしますか？とかね
いきなりお寺の鍵のところから始めて
お寺のお寺の権利証のところでいきなり始めて喋り出しちゃったんですね
それで我々は電話かけて医者に来てくださいと言っているところでしたけど
医者が来るまで待たなくちゃいけない
なんかもうあまりにも大騒ぎで
しゃべるはしゃべるは
もう大変で その長老の弟子たちが周りにいたんだけど
私はその日は用事があってそのお寺に行っただけなんですけど
まあ私よく知ってる長老であまりにも大騒ぎすると
私はすぐ分かったのは
本人がもしかするとこの病気で死ぬんだということを考えているんだと
だから混乱している いきなり言ったのは
先生持っていくつもりですかね
それ と この権利証と鍵をね
怒鳴ったんです 持っていくんですかね
そんなもの いきなり怒鳴っちゃったら
さっと全部消えちゃって
全部消えちゃって おとなしく座って
お医者さんが来るまで待とう
で それだけ 私はすごい年上でしたから
そんなこと言えたんだけど
周りにいる弟子たちは本当にみんな子供で若者で
20代ぐらいでね もうあまり何も言えなかったんですね
この 80歳の長老に で
その時もかなりこの頭
記憶 記憶力がなくなっちゃっていたし
私は昔 かなり体が大きかったんです
そこでもう後ですごく痩せちゃってたし
だから私わからないんですね
わからないんだけど どこかで声を覚えているんです
もうかなりしつこいこと
きついことを言うんだったよ
ですごいきついこと言われた途端
何のことなく受け入れちゃって
そうでないと病院に連れて行ったんだけど
看護婦さんにも面倒くさいし
医者にも面倒くさい 何言うかもうきりがないんだから
だから事実を言って脅した方がいいんです
おだてるんじゃなくて
慰めるんじゃなくて 時々
例えばすごく仕事をして大財産作った人だったら
それ言い始めるんですよ
私はこういう風に仕事をして
こんな風に苦労して  1 日 1 食しか食べないで
それもおにぎり 1個しか食べないで
もうこういう仕事を始めたんだと
それからまあこういうことをして
戦争の時はこんな苦労してとかね
やっとこのところまで持ってきたんだとかね
だから死ねないんですよ
このものに執着あるんだから
その場合ははっきり言った方がいいんですね
そこまで苦労して作ったってのは結局無意味ですね
そんなものは捨てなくちゃいけないんだから
そんな全部捨てなくちゃいけないんだから
無意味ですねとか言った方がいいんです
それで不思議に心が落ち着くんです
だから この何を教えるべきかというと
やっぱりこの あの そうやってみんな置いていくんだ
みんな旅人や 短い時間しかいないんだと
そう言われると笑えるんですよ
例えば 自分の息子がずっと喧嘩ばっかりして
もう勘当されている 勘当されている息子でも
やっぱりお見舞いに来たりする
我が強い人がその時でもあの調子でしょ
でもその時はもうまあまあ
みんなもう全部捨てていくんだ
旅人でしょうと こんなわずかな
わずかにこの中でみんないることだけですよとか言われたら
感動してた 自分の息子来たって
まあ君元気？とかなんとか一言葉言える
それで向こうも大変喜ぶでしょうに
勘当されている人も すごく向こうが喜んだったら
こちらも喜ぶでしょうに
ああ よかったと 仲直りできてとかということになるんです
そうするとまた喜びが出てくる
それで喜びの心で死ねるんですね
ですから チャーミングケアっていうのは当たり前の事実として何の不思議もない
そういう目で見なくちゃいけない
次に言いたいポイントは
このガンなんかになってきたら
すごく体がもうおかしくなったり
一番我慢できないのは
例えば吐いたりすることっていうのは
吐けばそれで問題解決するでしょ
この体の痛みなんですよ
いろんなところに痛みが出てくると
ご飯食べられないといえば
まあ現代的にはもう問題ないし
もうもう点滴で栄養をあげればいいしね
そういうのはあまり本人も問題にはしません
でも痛みなんかいろんなものが出てきたりしちゃうと
気持ち悪くなったりするとね
で どうしようもない その時また気が落ちる可能性はあります
気が弱くなる可能性はあります
その時は その痛みそのものをもう観察させちゃうんですね
だから この瞑想したことがない人だったら
誘導的に観察させればね
どこら辺痛いですか？と
どこからどこまで痛いんですかと
どのように痛いんですか？と
そこそれについて延々と質問する
そうすると その人がどうしようもなく
この自分の痛みというものを見るようになるんですよ
で 一言葉 また決まり言葉を言うんですね
まあ体っていうのはそういうものだと
そんなものはね やっぱり捨てた方がいいと思うのは正しいんだ
生まれてきてからも体というのは痛みだけですよと
今ただそれは集中的に攻撃しているだけですと
ですから全部捨てた方が楽だよと
ということを言ってあげると
体は自分のものでないと思いなさいと
で 気持ちは楽になります
楽な気持ちで死ねます
で 老天仏教でいうのは
この悔しい心で死ぬことは不幸だと
いやいやで死ぬのは不幸だと
死にたくない 死にたくないと思って死ぬことほど不幸なことはないんだと
まあ死ぬんだよという気持ちで死ななくちゃいけない
だからそれ観察しているんだったら
死ぬ時は面白くなるんですよ
例えば 死ぬことをずっと瞑想した人だったら
あ なるほど 今まで考えていたあの街に回っていた
死ぬ時はこういうことか
死ぬ時はこうなるんだ
ああ いろいろ幻覚も見えるんだとかね
それで面白がるだけ SF映画を見ているような感じで
だから用意して死ぬ 死にかけている人は用意していないと
用意してあげる だからポイントは落ち着いていること
当たり前の事実だと勘弁する人もされる側も認めること
常にこの面白く問題を見る
病気になったら 病気ってこんなもんかなとかね
これとんでもないものや
例えば心臓発作ね とんでもないことですね
この心臓発作っていうのは
だから心臓発作はすごい
この我慢できない 忍耐できない痛みでしょうね
どれぐらい強烈かというと
心臓発作というのは2回
受けちゃうともう逝っちゃいますからね
それぐらい痛いもんなんですよ
がんの痛みっていうのはそれほどないんですね
じわじわじわじわとゆっくりと時間をかけて痛みを起こる
辛そうさは全部まとめていっぺんに瞬時に来る
で まあそういうことだから
うん 体をね 何でしたっけ？アナータピンディカというお釈迦様の最期の弟子がいて
お釈迦様に対して随分年かじゃない
年間かなずると お釈迦様の面倒を見てあげた人で
巨大なお寺を作って寄付をして
毎日お坊さんたちに会っている
お坊さんたちのところがもうお釈迦様がその人のお寺に泊まっていると
毎日会って話したりしている
お釈迦様のこと心配してお釈迦様に質問はしない
みんな質問するんだから
私まで行って質問して迷惑をかけては来ないんだと
それを知っているお釈迦様はね
こいつはバカだから質問ぐらいすればいいんではないかということだから
まあ来たら何か教えてあげる
来たら何か教えてあげる
それでその人はもう死にかけちゃったんですね
病気になって で 末期状態治らない
で お釈迦様は行かなかったんですね
それでもで 自分の一番弟子であるね
サーリプッタ尊者よ あんたちょっと様子を見なさいよと
お釈迦様は心配していない
当たり前なんですね  どうせその人は苦しく死ぬわけじゃないし
お釈迦様は長い付き合いだから
まあそれでも様子見てこいと言ったら
サーリプッタ尊者が行って
お釈迦様もやっぱりお見舞いに来るようにと言われたんだと言って
どうですかね 体の調子はと
何か痛みは楽になってくるんですか？と聞いたんです
そしたら楽になるところじゃない
私の頭はこの皮のロープ
そういうもので 力強い人々が皮を巻いて両側で引っ張ってるような感じで
こちらへんは痛いんだと
お腹の方は鋭い刃物で刺しているように
胸の方がね すごく痛みがあるんだと
それどんどん強くなってくるんだと
だからサーリプッタ尊者っていうのはね
やっぱり 目は私のものだと思ったってもね
結局目から苦しみが生まれてくるだけで
ですから これ私のものじゃないと捨てた方がいいやと
耳は私のものだと思っているんだけど
耳からいろんな苦しみが生まれるんだと
それも捨てるんだと 体も私のものだと思っているんだけど
こんな苦しみが生まれてくるんだから
それ全部捨てるんだと
それで考え方 私の考え方と思っているんだから
苦しみが生まれてくる
それも捨てるんだと すべて捨てるんだよ
すべて捨てて 捨てて捨てて
何もないんだ という風な話をずっと言ったんですね
言ったら楽になったんですよ
これ私の体と思ったところで嫌になっちゃう
まあまあ捨てますよと
体と思ってさ ものすごい楽になって驚いちゃって
だから心は感動すると痛みが感じなくなっちゃうんですね
感動して驚いちゃって
なんていうお経ですかと
今一度もそんな話は聞いたことがないんだと
そしたらそんな話はね
この最後のあなた方にわからないんだから言わなかったんだよ
今まで理解しないんだから
言ったらそんなこと言わないで
これは先におっしゃってくれた方が良かったんではないかと
私は本当に楽になりましたと
すべて捨てるべきですよ
で言って 喜びで喜びで
ものすごい喜びを感じ始めたんです
もう痛みはもう飛んでいっちゃったんです
なんていう喜悦感か喜び感かと
思った時 サーリプッタさん
まあこれでいいや もう死ねるんだ
この人はと言って出てきたんです
まあじゃあ帰りますと
だから苦しみで苦しみでもう我慢できなくなった人には
瞬間に最高の喜びを作ってあげたんです
で じゃあ帰ります 言ったらもう帰って
その場でもうあの方が亡くなっちゃったんです
でも戻って遺体を見ようということじゃなくて
サーリプッタそのままお寺に帰っちゃったんですけど
で 帰って彼がもう天国に生まれ変わったんだと言ってますから
サーリプッタ尊者はお寺に行くと天国に生まれ変わって
その神様になってお釈迦様に挨拶したんだと
そしたらお釈迦様に報告すると
もうあの最後の信者さんが大変喜びを感じて
最後に息を止めたんだと
私はそのまま帰りましたと
ああそう 私も知ってますよ
もう挨拶に来ましたからと
お釈迦様も答えたんだそうですね
だからお釈迦様にサーリプッタ尊者が会う前に
お釈迦様は死んだ人とはもう喋ってるんです
ですから まあ決まりは小さい時楽しく生きていたんだから
後で欲ばっかし作ってわがままで苦しんでるだけで
そこを抑えれば生きることも楽しく生きていられる
死ぬ瞬間でもすごいニコニコと楽しく死ねるようにとしてあげなくちゃいけない
ターミナルケアする場合は
本当に得するのはケアする人々なんですよ
大体みんな損していると勘違いしているんですよ
寝たきりの人がいると
自分が損しているんだと
逆なんです ずっと面倒見なくちゃいけない人がもう死にかけている人がいるということで
この面倒を見る人も得しているんですよ
ものすごい もう想像を絶する得しているんです
なぜかと事実を見られる
自分も真理に目覚める
死は当たり前のことだと自分で体験できる
生きることはなんと苦しいかとわかる
私もあの大長老がね 最後の時は体が痛くて
いろんな痛みがあって
いかに苦しんでいたかと見ていたんだから
すごい自由な方が自由が全部なくなったところでもうかなりストレスでしょうに
そこで息をや止めた瞬間で
あの体と一緒にあの苦しみが全部なくなるでしょう
だからどうかで あ よかったという気持ち
こちらも生まれてくるんですね
苦しめないでよかったと
それはまあ 仏教の人々ですからね
別に死亡のこともあまり心配しないし
ちゃんとみんな用意しているし
それはいいんですけど
から 用意してない人の場合はね
本当にかわいそうですけどね
だから死の準備は生まれて間もない時からやってくださいというのは我々の言い方なんです
それだけ後回しにして
あんたがんで死に行ったところで
驚くのはよくないんですね
で 告知してもらわなくてはいけないんですよ
末期病気だったら告知してもらって
で 残りの短い１日は１日じゃなくて
日にちはどのようにするかと
残っている 2ヶ月間も
またまた我が強くて もう欲張って頑張って金儲かることに励むか
そんなものはバカバカらしいやと思って落ち着いているか
本人決めればよろしいしね
ですから 告知することはすごく必要なことなんです
ショックを受けちゃったら頭が悪いということで
そこら辺直してあげなくてはいけないんですね
で どうしようもないのは
このまあボケちゃって
何もわからなくなっちゃってね
コミュニケーション何も取れない場合は
まあどうすることもできませんね
だから若いうち 脳細胞を死なないように
ボケないようにちゃんと瞑想でもしておいた方がいいんです
なぜかというと 完璧にボケて
何ももうわからん 何もわからなくなっちゃって
耳も聞こえなくなっちゃって
死にかけて  2  3週間ね
機械の中にいても 生きてる人々にも何の手助けもできなくなっちゃう
だから汚れた心で死んでしまっちゃう
それは前もって気をつけた方がいいんですね
知恵だけは脳細胞が元気な時は作っておくんだということ
まあ大体まあこれぐらいの内容で十分だなと思います
とにかくすべての問題はどこから生まれてくるかというと
死ぬのは嫌というその一言葉から出てきます
それは嘘やとわかってるんだけど
心が認めたくない だから死にませんということで生きてます
ですから 今日の話は全部そのポイントだけなんです
死の瞑想も その心を直すための一つのプログラムなんです
そういうわけで 初期仏教ではそれほど天国の話と永遠な命とは言わない
必要ではない それはもう一つの慰めというか
ごまかしになってしまっちゃう
こう言ってもいいんです
あんたは正しく立派な人間で生きていたならば
まあ死後もそれなりの結果を得るでしょうと
あんたは良い人間で生活していたんだから
地獄に落ちるんだよというのはありえない話でしょうに
それはありえない話ですから
だから人にはね あんたこういうすごくいいことをしていたんだからね
いいんじゃないか 今はね
というふうに励むことはできます
もしいいことを一つもしたしたことがない人だったら
まああんたね よくも今まで何もいいことを一つもしてこなかったと
あんた死にませんよと
死んじゃったらとんでもないことになるんだと
まず脅す とんでもないことになるんだと
だからもう早くも頑張れと
心っていうのはすぐ変わるもんだから
1時間さえあればいいんやと
心直すために ちょっと 1時間あればいいんだと言って
このすごい死に対する恐怖感はとことん作ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
何もいいことをしないで
悪いことばっかりして
あるいは犯罪までして
それで死にかけちゃうと
もうものすごくおかしくなる
それで本人もおかしくなってるんだから
とことん脅して この極致のところまで
脅しちゃうんですよ もうすごく
そうするともう行き詰まりですよ
恐怖感の じゃああんたどうしますか？と
それでやっと心が変わるんです
だからいいことをした人だったら
まあ褒めてあげる 慰めてあげればいいんですよ
問題ないんですね あるいは
残り時間ももう慈しみの瞑想でもしましょうと言ったら
何のことなくしてくれる
問題ないんです 悪人はどうしますかというと
やってくれませんだから
わからないんだから そんな話は
だから悪人の場合は恐怖感のもう極端なところまで脅しちゃうんです
いくら泣いてももう気にしないで
だって当たり前ですよ
あんた一つもろくないいことをしたことがないで
親は裏切ったし 親は悩ませたし
先生も悩ませたらしい
泥棒もしたりしましたし
その上人まで殺したしと
よくもやったもんだなと
考えるは一欠けらもいいことないでしょうに
だからその結果 全部もうすぐもうすぐすぐ得られますよと
人間騙しちゃっても自分の心は騙せませんと
もうそろそろ もうすぐあなたは適当な結果を得られますよと
というと 自分も自分が死ぬんだということを知っているんだから
もうすぐそろそろですよと
地獄に落ちるの だから
この究極的な これ以上は恐怖感を感じないというところまで心が悩んじゃうんですよ
その瞬間で じゃああんたどうしますか？と
そこで教えてあげる 心を直すっていうことはいとも簡単にできますよと
ちょっと1時間30分ぐらいやればできますよと
じゃあこれからすべての生命に申し訳ないんだと
すべての生命が幸せでありますようにと
こんなような私もここまでみんなのおかげで生きてきたんだよと
というふうに慈しみの気持ちを作ってあげる
それで悪人でも地獄には落ちません
死ぬ時は喜びで 本当に慈しみを感じながら死んじゃったら地獄に落ちません
それでそれは仏教の死の人々に対する見方なんですね
それでストーリーがありまして
お釈迦様 これはもう話はほとんど終了しています
今一応